[Musique]
messieur bonjour bonjour bonjour On vous
interview aujourd'hui pour un site
internet qui s'appelle Serview on
voudrait avoir votre avis sur la crise
la finance le dévement de la finance
peut-être avoir votre avis pertinent
votre capacité d'expertise peut-être de
terrains pour jeanmanuel jeanmanuel Ros
présentez-vous bonjour j'ai travaillé
pendant 30 ans dans le domaine de la
finance comme trader et après comme
conseiller de différentes formules
d'investissement et depuis 3 ans j'ai
arrêté la finance
pour me consacré un moteur de recherche
qui s'appelle quant j'ai aussi CR un
livre sur la finance s'appelle le fric
j' 1989 et où j'expliqua pourquoi
j'allais arrêter de faire du
trading bonjour bonjour re bonjour tout
à fait est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présentercement bon moi j'ai j'ai fait
de la finance pendant 35 ans et donc en
banque et en banque d'affaires et en ce
moment je travaille dans trois
entreprise une qui a été créée il y a 15
ans et qui fait du de
l'intermédiation et qui s'appelle
tradition une autre qui est à Lausanne
et à Londres une
autre qui
finance l'infrastructure et et qui est
devenu un leader mondial et enfin une
affaire immobilière que
j'ai aidé à créé il y a 20 ans avec un
prêt de 200000 dollars et qui
aujourd'hui pèse 200 millions en ayant
fait quelques investissements judicieux
vous avez oublié une carte dans votre
manche vous êtes aussi un M important de
la Commission Trilatérale oui la
Commission Trilatérale
regroupe des tas de gens et donc je suis
l'un d'entre eux d'accord je vais vous
poser une première question pour entrer
dans le vif du sujet on a vu récemment
le plafond de la dette américaine arrivé
à son terme on voit le plafond de la
dette américaine arriver tous les 6 mois
à son
terme mais la croissance américaine
semble repartir est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu cette
différence de perception entre un état
qui arrive à tous les 6 mois à demander
qu'on relève le plafond de sa dette et
une croissance qui a l'air ou qui semble
repartir perv ben elle repart pour une
raison qui ne dépend ni des américains
ni de nous c'est un cycle hein et les
cycles
économiques durent entre 4 et 8 9 ans et
nous entrons très probablement dans un
cycle plus
favorable après qu'il y ait eu
destruction de
richesse de façon à ce que les les
méthodes anciennes et les industries un
peu trop surannées
aux États-Unis et ailleurs se renouvelle
et là en ce moment il on entre dans un
cycle différent alors la dette
américaine
euh elle augmente et
elle augmente d'une façon qui ne me
paraît pas démesuré étant donné les 320
millions d'habitants et les 24 trillions
de
dollars qui
caractéris euh
voilà Jean-Manuel Roson qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire un petit peu sur
votre métier passé de trader euh
qu'est-ce que vous avez pu voir dans les
salles de marché comment comment quel
était votre
rôle d'abord un mot sur la datte
américaine quand j'étais aux États-Unis
je vous souviens la première fois que
les marchés étaient inquiier pour la
dette américaine de mon expérience je
crois que c'était en 1981 la dette
américaine a toujours été renouvelé et
comme le dit Monsieur de carois elle
grandit mais elle grandit moins vite que
l'économie américaine et surtout en ce
moment et si l'économie américaine
grandit si vite en ce moment c'est parce
que il y a bien sûr un cycle nouveau
mais ce cycle est caractérisé par deux
choses à mon avis qui sont majeures et
qui expliquent pourquoi la croissance et
la richesse de demain va régler les
problèmes d'hier ce que beaucoup
d'analystes refusent de voir et donc les
gens continuent euh je dirais comme des
beauovins à être négatif sur le marché
qui monte depuis 5 ans et bien c'est
parce que la richesse de demain va les
problèm d'aujourd'hui et d'hier pourquoi
parce qu'il y a 1 milliard d'êtres
humains qui vont accéder à la classe
moyenne et ils vont le faire avec la
maîtrise de technologie d'information de
savoir qui sont sans précédent dans
l'histoire de l'humanité donc ça c'est
la force qui vient et ça fait 5 ans que
les marchés montent et ça fait 5 ans que
les mêmes analystes vous ditent c'est
épouvantable ça va très mal ça va casser
la gueule en nous lisant le journal
d'hierh on s'en fout ce qui compte c'est
le journal de demain voilà ça c'est ce
que je voulais vous dire sur ce sujet là
j'ai je vais je vais vous poser une
question sur la les salles des marchés
la la la profession de trader est-ce que
les traders s'occupent un petit peu des
fondamentaux de l'économie oou ils font
simplement de l'analyse technique est-ce
que c'est comment on fait pour être
trader comment vous prenez vos paris par
exemple sur les pétrolier est-ce que
vous avez quelqu'un qui dans les dans
les salles de marché fait de la veille
sur les produits pétroliers ou sur les
nouvelles technologies est-ce que tous
les matins vous avez une fiche
d'analystes qui qui qui vous renseigne
sur la réalité des des fondamentaux de
l'économie alors le le le il faut faire
une réponse un petit peu longue parce
que c'est une question complexe d'abord
il y a beaucoup de gens qui se disentê
trader et qui ne sont que des courtiers
les courtiers N sont pas la différence
entre courtiers TR et bien un trader est
quelqu'un qui prend une décision qui
engage les capitaux sur les marchés qui
sur les marchés des capitaux et un
courtier quelqu'un qui appelle un trader
pour lui suggérer une transaction
évidemment ce sont des niveaux de
comment dire il faut pour l'un et
l'autre des métiers des talents
différents pour être courtier il faut
être un bon vendeur et au fond si on
donne des mauvaises idées c'est embêtant
à court terme mais enfin on a toujours
trouvé un autre trader quand on en aura
ruiné un la banque en engagera un autre
et donc les les courtiers on euh
vraiment doivent être des bons vendeurs
plutôt que des bons analystes il y a des
analystes dans les sociétés de courtage
et parmi les traders le monde moderne a
créé beaucoup beaucoup de spécialités
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile de
vous répondre d'un coup juste un mot
dans ces spécialités il y a des gens qui
font du trading macro-économique basé
sur des analyses et où il faut un coup
d'œil global sur ce qui se passe dans le
monde vous refit qui vous fait remonter
l'information moi quand j'étais trader
évidemment je ne lisais jamais le
journal et je n'écoutais jamais personne
ce qui m'intéressait à moi c'était les
prix la vitesse à laquelle dis se
formait la façon dont je les voyais
bouger et comme je faisais surtout
beaucoup d'options les disférence de
prix entre une option et l'autre qui me
permettait de prendre des décisions donc
c'était un mix à mon époque c'est
extrêmement longtemps de d'analyse
macroéconomique extrêmement rapide et de
décisions de d'investissement basé sur
les prix relatifs de différents
instruments qui étaient de temps en
temps trop cher ou pas cher ça ça a
beaucoup évolué il y a beaucoup de
choses maintenant
Hervé ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est que les méthodes ont évolué la
complexité des modèles
mathématiques s'est accru et demande des
gens de plus en plus performants et la
vraie question
c'est qui doit prendre des positions et
pour moi les établissements bancaires ne
devraient pas prendre des positions pour
compte propre quel qu'il soit parce que
ils joue de plus en plus des sommes
importantes qui peuvent mettre en cause
les dépôts dont ils ont la
responsabilité vous parlez des effets de
levier des effets de levier et puis à
quoi quel est le rôle d'une banque le
rôle d'une banque est de prendre de
l'argent qui vient des clients et de le
mettre à la disposition d'autres clients
qui veulent créer de la croissance
économique la riche de la richesse voilà
bon alors je ne pense pas
que d'une façon très pointue lorsqu'une
banque joue le marché gagne quelquefois
des centaines de millions en jouant le
marché elle contribue au développement
économique jeanmanuel est-ce que vous
pouvez m'expliquer un petit peu la
philosophie des salles de marché la
philosophie des des personnes qui
évoluent dans les salles de marché
est-ce que le le but premier d'une salle
de marché c'est de prendre de l'argent
de faire de l'argent et de reprêter de
l'argent ou c'est de prendre de l'argent
et de prendre de
l'argent il y a beaucoup de choses et
dans une salle de marché dans des salles
de marché il y a certainement beaucoup
d'équipes qui ont beaucoup de rôles
différents je voudrais juste prendre un
petit peu
de je voudrais prendre un peu de recul
je v prendre un peu de recul je vous
faire une réponse générique non pas
générique
précise thoriquement et mon expérience a
été que le rôle principal de l'ensemble
des acteurs a essayé a été de créer de
la complexité qui leur permettait de
prendre de l'argent directement dans la
poche de leurs clients en leur vendant
des choses qu'il ne comprenaient pas à
des prix qui étaient trop hauts est- que
vous P ça c'est l'essence de l'activité
complexité des 30 dernières années après
il n'y a pas que ça je veux pas qu'on
pense qu'il n'y a que ça mais il y a
beaucoup de ça et c'est pour ça que les
banques se sont transformé en
gigantesques machines à vendre des
produits d'un côté il y a un trader
quelque part qui fait un produit très
complexe et qui le fait le plus cher
possible et après il y a une équipe même
si sur le nom de l'équipe il a marqué
euh euh managing directeur et associé
gérant pour le Moyen-Orient le gars qui
fait ça c'est quand même un gars qui au
fond ne comprend rien au pricing du
produit
et la façon dont il est structuré la
façon dont on le met à disposition du
client et ce qu'il rapporte lorsqu'il
est vendu à la banque mais ce qui sait
c'est que il a tout un tas de clients
auquel il faut qu'il en vend un maximum
donc ça ça c'est ce qui s'est passé ça
n'était pas évidemment le but originel
le but originel serait de faire en sorte
que les entreprises qui ont besoin
d'argent et les acteurs positifs de
l'économie qui savent prendre des
capitaux créer de l'emploi et créer de
la richesse puisse avoir tout le temps
cette somme à leur disposition hélas
dans les banques françaises aujourd'hui
nous en sommes très loin Hervé je vais
vous poser une question pour rebondir un
petit peu sur l'actualité on a vu il y a
y a pas très longtemps le scandale du
LIBOR de Lebor la manipulation de
certains taux interbancaire par des
traders et des grandes banques
euh je voudrais avoir votre opinion vous
homme
d'expérience est-ce que c'est une
logique est-ce que c'est une pratique
courante est-ce que les États de temps
en temps sont au courant est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous en penser qu'un
trader fixe un prix passe en intranet
des informations à ses copains traders
pour fixer un peu les prix d'une façon
un peu
obscure c'est une pratique courante euh
c'est une pratique courante parce que
les directions bancaires n'ont pas mis
en
œuvre la formule de David Rockfeller
pour la Chase qui a permis à la Chase
pendant les 40 ans où j'étais avec eux
de ne pas avoir de difficultés liées à
des pratiques douteuses quelle était
cette règle s'il y a un doute il y a pas
de doute c'est-à-dire que chaque fois
qu'un trader chaque fois qu'un directeur
chaque rencontré et pratiquer des des
des des décisions contraires à l'éthique
de base d'une maison il était renvoyé
bon cela signifie
que toutes ces pratique il faut prendre
comme hypothèse qu'elles sont connues
des chefs de service qu'elles sont des
directions générales et qu'elles sont
tolérées à cause
des bénéfices
importants que que ces pratiques
induisent et pour la banque et pour les
membres de l'équipe
jeanu plus j'aimerais dire quelque chose
de précis là-dessus le le mécanisme
précis de perversion du système dans les
cas où il a été perverti car il n'a pas
été fait référence à votre livre car il
n'a pas été perverti tout le temps et
partout mais le mécanisme précis c'est
le suivant et et je le date parce que je
l'ai vu de la fin des années 80 à un
moment donné dans la finance la finance
appartenait principalement à ces
propriétaires c'est chez Goldman sack
chez S brers les propriétaires c'était
les associés gérants et ils étaient
responsables sur leur biens et donc
quand il y avait un doute il y avait pas
de doute parce que le risque était pour
eux à un moment donné ces maisons sont
devenu des sociétés par action
l'actionnaire en bourse était celui qui
portait le risque et les chefs de
service les directeurs c'est-à-dire les
chefs se sont app perçu d'une chose
merveilleuse s'il donnait beaucoup
beaucoup de bonus à beaucoup d'indiens
il pouvait en réclamer un pour eux et le
chef du chef aussi et le chef du chef
aussi et finalement ça est devenu
exclusivement uniquement oui une course
au bonus et c'est ça qui a ouvert la
porte à des excès alors il n'y a pas eu
que des excès mais il y a eu beaucoup
d'excès et le deuxième raison c'est que
les contrôles internes ont
considérablement failli quand je prends
une banque où j'avais quand même une
respon ilité direction générale il nous
a fallu 4 ans hein alors que j'étais
conscient un peu du marché puisque
j'étais trader au début de ma vie
professionnelle pour installer des
contrôles en profondeur sur toutes ces
transactions et les
auditeurs ont mis des années à attirer
dans leur rang d'ancien traders pour
pouvoir vérifier des questions de
salairire c'est pour des questions de
salaire pour des questions de confort
comment est-ce qu' ont fait entrer deux
traders dans une équipe de 10
contrôleurs c'est pas aisé à gérer hein
et cetera donc tout le monde a été en
retard et tout le monde a été en retard
à la fois parce que les sommes en jeu
pour les entreprises étai très
importants les gains pour les individus
encore plus et donc il y a eu une
conivance généralisée on va on va
rebondir sur l'actualité on va rebondir
sur l'actualité avec les amendes que
certaines grandes banques euh ont reçu
des gouvernements et des autorités de
régulation des marchés euh pour faire
une comparaison une grande banque qui a
payé son amende pour faire le parallèle
c'est l'équivalent d'une amende de 25 €
pour quelqu'un qui gagne 50000 €
c'est-à-dire une broutille euh Hervé je
vais rebondir sur vous est-ce que les
États il comprennent quelque chose
est-ce que la la complexité des des
mécanismes de marché des mécanismes de
finances des mécanismes de salle de
marché la complexité des traders
n'embrume pas les régulateurs des
gouvernements le mot les états est un
mot vague il y a des il y a des
directions spécialisées au trésors
d'accord on va prendre l'exemple de
Bercy est-ce que les fonctionnaires de
Bercy sont suffisamment compétents et
courageux pour demander des comptes ils
le font ils ont amélioré leurs équipes
ils n'arrivent pas pas plus que les aut
aiteur extérieur à vérifié le fin fond
et le détail des opérations qui sont
faites et qu'il arrive
que une banque que je connais très bien
a perdu 200 millions de dollars qui sont
qui ont été comptabilisés un mois après
l'arrivée des auditeurs des commissaires
au comptes et des et des contrôleurs en
d'autres termes ces opérations sont
extraordinairement complexes
et l'État les commissaires au comptes
les les les organismes de contrôle
interne sont rarement dotés étaient
rarement dotés des hommes qu'il fallait
ils le sont beaucoup plus aujourd'hui
jeanmanuel
unot je pense que il y a toujours et il
y aura encore des problèmes spécifiques
où le contrôle est difficile le contrôle
est un peu lent les gens qui font le
contrôle n'ont pas tout le pouvoir tout
l'accès et au fond finalement peuvent
avoir toujours un petit peu de retard
cependant je pense que d'une façon
systémique si on prenait tout le système
financier qu'on prend de dates 2007
quand le système financier était trufé
de subfe et de trucs extrêmement
dangereux qui allait exploser et 2013 ou
2014 aujourd'hui je pense que d'une
façon globale ça va beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup mieux et moi je suis encore
aujourd'hui très positif sur l'économie
mondiale sur la croissance et sur les
marchés je pense bien sûr qu'une crise
est possible je ne crois pas qu'elle
viendra de ce même genre de problème
elle viendra d' de selon vous là il
faudrait le journal d'après-demain et je
ne l'ai pas je ne sais pas je ne peux
pas dire la Chine peut-être
oui en général elle vient toujours d'un
endroit surprenant donc c'est difficile
à dire là je peux je peux pas vous
répondre aujourd'hui on ne on ne voit
vraiment et c'est très bizarre quand on
est français on va je vais choquer
aujourd'hui on on ne voit que que du que
que du rose ou du rouge ou du bleu à
l'origon c'estàd que y on voit pas de
danger on voit un monde qui va de plus
en plus vite de plus en de mieux mieux
en mieux où il y a de plus en plus
d'opportunités de plus en plus de savoir
et de talent et de plus en plus de
solutions et de plus en plus de capitaux
voilà pour des projets c'estàdire que ce
qui manque à l'heure actuelle c'est les
projets parce que il y a en gros une
trentaine de trillions de dollars
investis dans du monétaire dans des
prêts aux États et cetera je veux dire
l'argent il est là pour pour pour
vulgariser un petit peu ces capitaux
sont sur une promesse d'un travail futur
si je synthétise très trivialement le
ils sont basés sur des bénéfices énormes
réalisés par des pays qui vendent des
matières premières ou sont très
efficaces comme le Japon l'Allemagne et
et la Chine donc c'est des réserves
entre les emploi que ces pays font et et
les surplus qu'ils ont donc et ils vont
en croissant
très bien jeanmanuel les matières
premières qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez globalement que elles vont monter
ou continuer à monter le prix le prix
des matières premières continuera à
monter oui je je pense B il y en a
beaucoup qui sont redescendus ça s'est
calmé et cetera mais dans la mesure où
comme je viens de dire il y a un
milliard d'individus qui accèdent à une
consommation croissante il faut bien
qu'il consomme quelque chose et donc ça
va pousser le prix de tout vers le haut
des actions de l'immobilier pour les
plus riches des warols et des bascas et
de l'art contemporain et des matières
premières qu'il va falloir consommer
mais ça et alors ce qui est complexe
dans cette raésonnement c'est que
évidemment on peut s'en plaindre pour
ceux qui eux n'ont pas accès à ce monde
là puisque ça rend tout plus cher mais
on ne peut pas s'en plaindre pour le
reste de l'économie car cette montée des
prix c'est aussi un enrichissement
notamment pour les producteurs de ces
matières premières dans les pays
émergents je vais me faire dans dans
justement cette option de de de de mon
grandissant avec une un marché qui va
exploser au niveau
des des pays
émergents et et des pays développer
regardez la croissance aux États-Unis un
mot peut-être sur la spéculation sur les
matières premières justement en parlant
de ça alors il faudrait vraiment
vraiment vraiment et c'est c'est très
très facile à faire l'endigué moi j'ai
créé je parle de moi en 2000 j'ai créé
une ONG qui s'appelle life organization
et qui suggéit qu'il y ait peut-être que
vous allez très opposé à ça qui suggérer
qu'il y ait dans le monde des
financements innovants une taxe sur les
transactions sur les marchés dérivés de
matières premières notamment les futures
les options de machères premières pour
une raison simple regardez c'est très
très facile on a tous les moyens
modernes il y a des chambres de
compensation donc à chaque fois qu'un
futur sur un marché à terme agricole où
une option est échangée on sait
exactement Infiné qui est celui qui l'a
acheté et vendu et on peut savoir si
c'est un spéculateur pour le compte d'un
particulier dans une banque privée pour
le compte d'un fond fond
d'investissement ou un agriculteur qui
en a besoin pour éger sa position il n'y
a aucun problème pour prendre 1 % sur
l'aller-retour au spéculateurs qui se
serent de ce marché uniquement pour
essayer de gagner de l'argent et de ne
rien prendre au producteurs et donc
taxer ces marchés de cette façonlà une
mini taxe à la marge et donner cet
argent soit aux États pour se
désentetter soit au développement pour
tout un tas de choses qui sont très
faciles à faire avec les agences
internationale contre la maladie pour
l'éducation dans le tier monde c'est
quelque chose qui est absolument
indispensable et nécessaire et la seule
raison par laquelle on ne le fait pas
c'est parce que il y a un lobby des
banques qui fait peur à la terre entière
et qui dit le monde va s'effondrer si on
ne le fait pas mais ça c'est vraiment de
à mon sens si on le fait si on le fait à
mon sens c'est vraiment du mou pour le
chat c'est c'est faux c'est un mensonge
c'est exact c'est exact nous devons
sanctionner d'une façon ou d'une autre
la spéculation ure et permettre les
opérations de couverture des producteurs
la difficulté c'est dans la mise en
œuvre hein parce que il faut avoir
l'accord de 30 ou 40 pays car si nous
mettons ça dans toute l'Europe et que on
retrouve dans une île lointaine
d'océani 30 banques qui font ça à partir
de làou de Caraïb ou de Caraïbes si vous
préférez donc pour ça il faut
avoir l'accord des 30 principaux pays
dans le monde à commencer par les
États-Unis mais c'est fondamental de
faire ça et il
va ça va pénétrer
lentement les élites américaines
européennes et asiatiqu je pense que
dans les 10 à 15 ans qui viennent on
aura fait un progrès parler des élites
un mot un tout petit mot alors je vous
en prie monsieur a raison c'est comp de
convaincre les les élites ça fait 32 ans
que je travaille dans le monde de la
finance j'ai des copains donc depuis ce
temps-là donct certains ont des grands
hedge fund aux États-Unis j'en ai appelé
deux parmi les plus grands hedge fund
pour leur dire soutiens-moi sur cette
micro taxe sur les marchés
drivés c'était il y a 2 ans j'essaie
encore de les ravoir au téléphone ils me
prennent pour un fou ils veulent ils en
veulent pas ils ont tort et un jour ils
comprendront oui ils vont comprendre
quand la fourche sera à leur porte ça
c'est sûr ou HERV vous parlez des élites
vous quand vous vous le le le le concept
élite c'est c'est les 1 % le fameux 1 %
qu'est-ce que ça raisonne qu'est-ce que
veut dire élite pour vous l'élite pour
moi c'est d'abord les gens responsables
hein donc il faut qu'ils aient des
responsabilités et on n'a pas de
responsabilité si on n pas de pouvoir
hein donc pouvoir
responsabilité conjuguer les deux
ensemble vous arrivez à un petit groupe
de d'hommes qui sont quelques milliers
dans le monde qui peuvent prendre des
décisions c'est ces gens-là qu'il faut
convaincre et où commencer par les
banques centrales hein car une banque ne
va pas aller à l'encontre de ce que lui
dit une banque centr centrale parce que
si elle le fait et une banque peut
toujours avoir une crise de liquidité ou
ou une autre crise d'une autre nature
elle a besoin de la Banque centrale donc
il y a sur peut-être 10000 personnes qui
prennent des décisions il y en a 20 qui
comptent ce sont les 20 premières
banques centrales du monde si ensemble
elle décide que ce qui vient d'être
proposé et que je soutiens entièrement
c'est-à-dire une taxe sur la pure
spéculation qui n'est pas complexe à
mettre en œuvre est mise est appliqué
nous aurions fait un pas en avant
considérable alors que faire de cet
argent en effet c'est une très bonne
question mais collectons-le d'abord et
puis ensuite on trouvera des
applications utile de par leementonde je
voudrais rebondir sur la Commission
Trilatérale et ce fameux complexe ce
fameux concept d'élite est-ce que vous
pouvez nous développer un petit peu nous
expliquer ce qu'est la Commission
Trilatérale comment sont sont effectué
les prises de décision est-ce qu'il y a
un comité directeur est-ce que ça se
passe un petit peu comme les gens qui
dirigent la banque centrale est-ce que
ce sont des gens influents je vous
écoute essayez de de nous démistifier ou
de rentrer dans le détail de la
commission trale l'idée de la Commission
Trilatérale vient de David Rockfeller il
y a 35 ans il a
réuni quelques dizaines d'Européens
d'Américains de japonais en leur disant
écoutez on a des problèmes en
commun par
exemple les relations avec la Chine par
exemple les relations avec ce qui était
à l'époque l'URSS
essayons d'avoir des positions communes
qui soient dans l'intérêt général est-ce
que la Commission Trilatérale fait
pression pour par
exemple lancer une taxe sur la
spéculation
elle pourrait elle a pourquoi elle ne le
fait pas parce que elle
a le mot pression me gêne à partir du
moment où vous avez 150 européens 120
américains 150 fant asiatique et nous
avons mis 10 ans à avoir des Chinois
dans notre groupe qui euh ont écouté les
raisons pour lesquelles on devrait
continuer à libérer le commerce
contrôler beaucoup plus ardemment le le
système bancaire éviter la
spéculation être d'une plus grande
générosité à l'intérieur des pays à
l'extérieur et et globalement vis-à-vis
des plus pauvres euh ça crée un
mouvement
et notre rôle n'est pas de prendre des
décisions c'est de prendre des
orientations reprises par des dirigeants
de tout bord nous avons toujours des des
dirigeants politiques qui viennent d'un
parti et qui viennent de l'opposition
nous avons des gens qui viennent des
syndicats et et et du et des affaires et
ensemble on essaie d'élaborer des
solutions au problèmes des migration de
des capitaux
et nous essayons ensemble de travailler
et le seul fait de travailler ensemble
pendant 3 jours quelques années de suite
fait que notre mentalité évolue Hervé un
dernier petit bout pour finir sur sur
l'organisation
euh quand vous quand quand quand la
Commission Trilatérale a accès à des
gens très importants al vous nous avez
dit de
syndicats peut-être du journalisme un
petit peu non oui absolument est-ce que
d'un point de vue extérieur ça peut être
perçu par la population comme une
collusion malsine que des syndicats se
retrouvent avec des chefs d'entreprise
et des journalistes autour d'une table
table pour vulgariser se tape la poogne
ou se font la bise ou échange sur des
sujets un peu plus complexes est-ce que
vous trouvez pas qu'il y a un petit peu
un conflit d'intérêt et je vous prends
un exemple des gens puissants cast
j'aime pas le mot cast mais des gens
puissants d'une certaine élite comme
dans tout échantillon de population il y
a souvent des délinquants ou des gens
qui sont pas de bonne foi est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas que ces gens qui ce
tout petit pourcent au sein de ce tout
petit pourent la l'impact de nuisance
peut être très très important et comment
vous faites pour on va dire chasser les
les gens petits canard ou sa r c'est
très simple la règle de David Rockfeller
s'il y a un doute sur l'intégrité de qui
que ce soit dans une dans dans dans le
groupe de la Trilatérale il est
immédiatement sorti c'est arrivé c'est
arrivé absolument non
non alors là pas aujourd'hui non pas
aujourd'hui jamais non non non non non
non Jean-Manuel vous luez parler oui je
disais que je voulais réagir et dire
queune fois de plus l'ennemi quand la
Commission Trilatérale se réunit et fait
des suggestions il y a un lobbing
inverse souvent qui se met en place pour
que les choses n'arrivent pas notamment
par exemple dans le cadre des micro
taxes sur les marchés financiers et
cette et cette et ce lobbying est
inspiré une fois de plus de l'envie de
bonus c'estàdire que a tout un tas de
Gus qui se disent oh là là mais si on
fait ça je pas pouvoir continuer à
gagner autant d'argent à faire ce que je
veux il faut surtout arrêter et du coup
et ça c'est assez puissant parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de gens qui on veulent des
bonus et et je dois dire quand même la
chose suante c'est que il me semble que
dans cette univers là dans cet univers
là et dans d'autres univers qui est
celui je crois des très grandes sociétés
il y a énormément de gens qui croi
mériter des très gros salaires qu'ils
ont et c'est faux c'est absolument faux
car réalité si vous essayez de réfléchir
à où est la création de valeur est-ce
que c'est dans l'activité de l'individu
ù on sait ce que tout ce que la
l'organisation la société apporte à cet
individu pour pouvoir faire son activité
et vous prenez par exemple les traders
pour être trader c'est-à-dire pour
pouvoir fabriquer un produit que au bout
de la chaîne on va vendre très cher à un
client quelque part il faut des lignes
de crédit des bureaux de la crédibilité
et cetera tout un système monstrueux
qu'il faut gérer et le gars qui est là
on peut le prendre on peut l'ter on peut
en mettre un autre il est assez
remplaçable et donc en réalité la valeur
appartient à 98 % à l'organisation et à
2 % à l'individu et un ensemble
d'individus de collusion essaent de
faire croire que c'est le contraire que
c'est 50 50 et tant que ça continuera on
sera en échec mais c'est faux c'est
juste faux her des solutions
apportez-nous des solutions il y en a il
y en a une c'est de ne pas faire ce qu'a
fait chas Morgan ch Morgan perdu 9
milliards l'année dernière et Morgan qui
est une banque oui oui oui une très
grande banque la première banque
mondiale et le patron en
2013 a reçu 23 millions de bonusard à 23
millions ou 23 milliards non 23 millions
de bonus c'est colossal pour un individu
qui a perdu 9
milliards voilà alors ce que je veux
dire c'est que que faire avoir des
conseil d'administration responsable que
la banque centrale vérifie que les
normes de rémunération des dirigeants
soit cohérente et juste car là où il y a
injustice ça répercute sur l'intégrité à
tous les niveaux d'une organisation on n
pas parlé de sanction euh et ben on
aurait dû renvoyer le monsieur Diamond
Jimmy Diamond ah mais absolument il a
perdu 9 milliards
he renvoyer ou le mettre en prison bon
ça c'est votre problème c'est pas le
mien hein le mien c'est que les banques
doivent gérer
leur conseil
d'administration leurs dirigeants en
fonction de l'intérêt à long terme des
clients de la maison et de l'industrie
et là si on prend le cas de GP Morgan 9
milliards de Provis
un président qui reçoit 23
millions ça n'est pas cohérent avec
l'intérêt général alors justement dans
le je reprends le mot de l'intérêt
général dans la Commission
Trilatérale globalement d'illeurs dans
tes
grandses grandsank très particulier
comme auss CFR pourquoi pas et vous parz
tout à l'heure de représentation de
toutes catégories oui où sont les jeunes
où sont les jeunes où sont représentant
je suis ravi de cette question parce que
nous sommes en train de formuler la
proposition à l'intérieur de la
Commission
Trilatérale de recruter des gens de 30 à
45 ans parce que les autres ont quand
même un âge plus avancé et de façon à
les intégrer dans notre réflexion mais
ça prend du temps parce que vous êtes
allé vous êtes- la Russie arrivé de
d'inviter des gens des représentants
j'allais dire de de la sagesse populaire
quelque part j'ai la bpè qui me vient en
tête il n'est plus là il est plus de ce
monde mais des représentants de ce type
là est-ce qu'on a pris un Abbé Pierre
laïque à l'intérieur de
oui on prend des gens qui
ont qui ont une réflexion qui n'est pas
ér
altéré ni par l'argent ni par la
position politique on a des gens qui
sont des sages
d'acord parce que je voudrais je
voudrais dire un mot de même que j'ai
j'ai dit que l'ennemi de des solutions
qu' c'est on va dire le bonus et Don
bien l' vu dans le cas de Monsieur
Diamond qui lui en haut tout en haut et
qui lui se don un trè gros bonus qui
permet à tout le monde en bas d'en avoir
un aussi je crois que la solution et
quand vous dites par exemple c'est les
20 banques centrales qui dev devrait
commencer à agir c'est vrai je sais que
les banques centrales sont souvent
souvent indépendantes du pouvoir
politique mais je pense que la seule
solution vraiment et politique
c'est-à-dire que il faut que je réondu
sur ce que vous dites que suffisamment
d'individus dans la société prennent
conscience à la fois des problèmes et
des solutions pour élire des politiciens
qui eux imposeront une solution et
prenons un exemple de comment ça peut se
faire comment ça peut se faire à la
marge fa pas avoir des politiciens qui
soient suffisamment à ce momentlà euh
volontaire et détacher de la de la haute
finance pour pouvoir imposer ces
décisions puisqu'ils savent à l'heure
actuelle que s'ils imposent ce type de
décision au marché financier comme le
disait monsieur de carmois tout à
l'heure si ça passe pas tout droit ça
passera par à côté et eux leur prochain
mandat
saute je je pense que d'abord il faut
faire une prise de conscience générale
auprès du plus grand nombre possible de
personnes il faut qu'un jour un
politicien majeur dans un pays majeur la
France l'Italie les États-Unis
l'Angleterre l'Allemagne soit élu sur un
thème qui reprend ses problématiques de
façon centrale et que peu à peu il
l'impose au reste c'est ce qu'on appelle
le tipping point il y a un moment donné
où ça va
s'infléchir le point de basculement et
où ces problématiques vont se diffuser
dans la société ça ne peut être que par
la prise de conscience des individus qui
élisent des politiciens qui leur disent
oui ce thème là c'est le mien je
l'approprie je le reprends et je
l'impose et je vais vous dire quelque
chose qui va peut-être vous surprendre
on a failli et ça ne veut pas dire que
je vote pour lui ça ne veut pas dire que
j'ai soutenu ce qu'il a fait par
ailleurs on a failli avoir ça en France
avec Nicolas Sarkozy qui à la fin de son
mandat avait parfaitement compris une
chose c'était l'intérêt de la taxe de la
microtaxe sur les marchés innovants et
qui voulait
l'imposer juste sur ce sujet là il était
très prêt d'être le premier politicien
majeur qui était prêt à porter ce
sujetl c'est exact ENF c'est factuel qui
est dit euh comment créer un mouvement
et ben il faut d'abord convaincre les
journalistes économique il faut
convaincre euh des euh des des journaux
tout courts et il faut avoir des
réunions avec des députés moi j'ai
participé à certaines de ces réunions il
faut dire que nos députés connaissent
assez peu de choses sur les questions
financières et économiques et peuvent
s'améliorer mais sont souvent curieux
hein et c'est un long travail
pédagogique alors justement on parle des
des journalistes peut-être que c'est ça
n'est pas assez relayé par les médias du
mainstream et je profiterai de ce cette
petite réflexion pour me dire comment se
fait-il que
des que 10 simplement 10 personnalités
se regroupant dans un hôtel amène une
foule de Paparadis alors que vous-même
quand vous vous réunissz pour la
Trilatérale personne n'en parle nul part
on fait référence par par rapport au
bildelberg qui qui s'est déroulé en
Angleterre qui a énormément de Paparadis
de monde aux portes mais mais mais à
l'intérieur il nait on navait pas accès
à à ce qui était débattu et on se
souvient de Monsieur Y Calvi notamment
il y a quelques il y a peut-être 2 ans
qui découvrait ce qui était que le
groupe Bilderberg sur sa propre antaine
votre avis sur le journal oui moi moi
moi si vous voulez le le le
le c'est c'est une bonne question mais
je vais je vais pas répondre d'une façon
euh qui serait induite par votre
question en d'autres termes je ne pense
pas que la trilatéral et ayant été à son
comité exécutif euh
doivent faire de la publicité
s'expliquer
et parce que c'est pas son objet son
objet et bien précis c'est de prendre
les sujets qui nous fâchent avec les
États-Unis la Chine le
Japon sujet monétaire liberté de
circulation euh euh des hommes
euh qualité de la justice euh effort
militaire toutes ces questions-là et
d'en discuter euh euh de façon privée et
de faire émer
d'autres idées qui vont influencer en
gros 400 personnes dans le monde c'est
ça notre objectif est-ce qu'on peut
faire une suggestion oui la suggestion
qu'on aurait à formuler c'est de rendre
quand même une partie de vos travaux
publics que l'Internet puisse aussi
réfléchir avec vous et que vous puissiez
bénéficier de l'intelligence
collaborative d'internet je pense qu'
l'heure actuelle nous pensons à l'heure
actuelle que la force de l'internet
c'est de de mettre
les cerveaux et il il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes sur le net qui
pourrai peut-être vous aider donc
essayez de rendre un peu plus public vos
travaux d'avoir des des des live stream
pendant vos conférences sans rendre tout
public il y a un proverbe dans le
renseignement qui dit si tout le monde
parle rien ne marche mais si personne ne
parle ça on meurt
ouais oui oui oui que nous dions
améliorer notre communication vous avez
raison hein la réalité quand même que
depuis 30 ans nous avons fait évoluer
les mentalités aux États-Unis par
rapport à l'Europe la Russie et la Chine
en Chine par rapport aux libertés même
chose provisoirement à une époque en
Russie nous avons renforcé la tendance
au libre échange nous avons établi des
ponts très nombreux et invisible qui
doivent le respter dans la collaboration
en Europe avec la Russie et les
États-Unis la Chine et le Japon dans le
domaine scientifique donc on a fait un
travail invisible important
permettez-moi de dire que je je
corrobore un peu ce que dit disent nos
amis de thinkervview c'est je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a extrêmement besoin
et et je pense que ce sont les
internautes et ce sont les gens partout
dans le monde qui ont besoin d'une haute
autorité morale dans laquelle puisse
avoir confiance car il y a une vraie
crise de confiance en même temps qu'il y
a une diffusion massive du savoir
c'està-dire qu'il y a de plus en plus de
gens qui comprennent les problèmes et
qui évidemment étant incapable ou
impuissant de les résoudre se mettent à
désespérer et beaucoup de jeunes sont
dans cet état là et donc s'il y avait
une autre autorité morale je comprends
très bien que depuis 30 ans vous avez
influencé un petit nombre de décideurs
mais je crois que si c'était possible si
vous pouviez être représentatif d'une
morale crédible vis-à-vis d'un très très
grand nombre de gens ça serait pas mal
non plus oui parce que je je je rebondis
justement sur cette cette autorité
morale ainsi que sur les personnes
influent dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure euh quelque part chacun agissant
un peu pour sa paroisse euh au sein de
ce cercle de membres extrêmement
influent vous comptez sur une sorte
d'équilibre des intérêts
est-ce qu'on peut pas aussi craindre
nous gens extérieurs à ces à ces cercles
euh une des convergences d'intérêt euh
parmi les personnes décisionnaires qui
nous pousseraient vers quelque chose qui
n'irait pas forcément dans le sens du
bien
commun ce que nous on il aura pas un
équilibre des intérêts il va y avoir un
équilibre des débats c'est-à-dire que
nous allons trouver des Américains qui
vont être très euh opposés à certaines
politiques en Afrique ou ou ou ailleurs
des Japonais qui ne veulent pas libérer
leur
commerce interne nous allons trouver
toutes ces opinions exprimées et parce
qu'elles seront exprimées avec force
prenons la libération du commerce au
Japon par des Américains et
desonais les dirigeants japonais vont
revenir chez eux et dire écoutez il faut
il faut prendre ça en considération et
ils vont contribuer à faire évoluer al
évoluer vers
coi vers plus de démocratie parce que
c'est le thème central
donc plus de liberté plus de gens qui
participent aux décisions plus de
considération pour l'intérêt général
alors est-ce que nous comprenons bien à
tout moment ce qu'est l'intérêt général
il y a matière à s'améliorer et nous
l'essayons nous venons venir des gens
opposés à nos vues hein et qui ont des
vues opposées entre eux de façon à bien
discuter bon et nous restons je pense
modeste c'estàd dire que très bien on
débat on a des spécialistes et puis
chacun repart dans son pays en essayant
de faire bouger la chose d'accord donc
on on il n'est pas illusoire d'imaginer
de voir des groupes tels que le vôtre
pousser des des nouvelles
solutionsé dans dans les je parle dans
la transition énergétique qui s'impose à
aujourd'hui des nouvelles solution qui
pourrait mettre en péril des lobbyes qui
pèsent des milliards je pense au Pétro
est-ce que est-ce que vous arrivez
jusqu'au choc frontal avec les lobbyes
est-ce que la Commission Trilatérale par
ses préconisations on arrive au choc
frontal on arrive à ce que sur des
sujets comme l'énergie nous avons deux
thèses exprimé à une réunion où il y a
150 personnes absolument opposé quelles
sont-elles le le degré d'investissement
qui doit être soutenu par les États euh
sur les nouvelles énergies
euh il y a une thèse d'un grand pays
européen qui a investi des dizaines de
milliards
et et qui n'a obtenu aucun résultat
l'emagne euh et vous avez d'autres pays
qui comme le nôtre qui pense que
euh une industrie
nucléaire très exigeante en matière de
sécurité et quelque chose qu'il faut
conserver tandis que nous avons des vues
absolument opposé à la France qui
s'expriment à la Trilatérale Jean
manuel vous avez été gestionnaire de
fortune de très grosse fortune est-ce
que vos clients vous demandent
simplement du rendement où il y avait
vraiment une une éthique dans
l'investissement est-ce que par exemple
vous aviez une partie de votre
portefeuille pour de nouveaux projets ou
des choses comme ça c'est très spécial
dans cette période où j'ai fait ce
métier on avait un
notre but était
de soutenir
financièrement des
entrepreneurs compétents dans des
métiers intéressants c'est-à-dire de ce
point de vue-là dans des métiers à bonne
marge et donc toute l'exercice que j'ai
fait pendant les 15 ou 16 ans où j'ai
fait ce métier c'était de trouver des
gens qui étaient forts dans des métiers
qui étaient bons et de trouver des
façons avec divers clients de euh leur
permettre de grandir de ce point de vuel
il y avait une finalité qui était
évidente c'est queon a aidé dans
certains cas à la création massive
d'emploi puisqu'on a mis des capitaux
aux mains de gens qui partant à 12 sont
arrivés à 7000 c'est pas mal mais je ne
dis pas que c'était le seul but le but
c'était de trouver des façons de à long
terme à moyen terme à court
terme j'ai envie de vous dire que le
long terme c'est une spéculation ratée
devient un investissement mais mais
c'était pas pas ça l'idée l'idée c'était
de trouver dans le monde entier et dans
différentes industries des gens qui
étaient très bons dans ce qu'il
faisaient de leur donner accès au
capital nécessaire à leur croissance ça
a bien marché une question est-ce que
l'éducation est un
placement avec de bonnes
Marg écoutez je je ne sais pas pour vous
direé je suis pas sûr que l'éducation
soit un domaine qui soit à 100 % et
uniquement de la responsabilité des
privés je crois que c'est forcément
aussi de l'État mais d'une façon
générale l'éducation et le placement
avec la meilleure marge puisque c'est
par l'éducation et par le savoir que
l'on crée la richesse la croissance le
savoir la démocratie et l'emploi donc
sans éducation il n'y a rien c'est un
placement sur du long terme oui mais
c'est tout dépend qu'il fait est-ce que
c'est l'état ou est-ce que c'est des
privés
d'accord bonne question
HERV je vous vois sourire mais oui je
souris parce que je pense que quand des
clients me confient de
l'argent je pense long termein j'ai
toujours pensé long terme donc c'est un
placement raté non nous avons choisi il
y a 15 ans d'investir dans des
PME une PME il y a 15 ans une nouvelle
PME chaque
année on a créé 1000
emplois et on l'a fait selon des règles
qui vont à l'encontre du marché pas un S
de l'État pas un S des banques les
particuliers qui s'associent le fond
pour 15 à 20 ans hein et ça a marché ça
a marché parce qu'on a eu des un
dirigeant qui savait choisir là où il
investissait c'est tout donc
je continue oui bon
donc moi je crois que les gens qui vous
confient leur argent ils ont ce que
j'appelle une propension au risque et il
faut en tenir compte mais s'ils sont
prêts à prendre des risques ils ont été
prêts à les prendre avec nous et bien on
les a pris
euh on a gagné de l'argent pendant 15
ans on n'a pas perdu une société hein et
on s'est concentré sur le fait que on
avait pas d'argent des banques et pas
d'argent de l'État ce qui est
intéressant dans le risque c'est que ce
que vous dites prouve que souvent ce que
les gens pensent être extrêmement risqué
ne l'est pas tellement et ce qu'il pense
ne pas être risqué l' énormément je vous
donne exemple simple si en 2007 vous
décidez d'acheter un panier des
meilleures valeurs du monde les C
meilleure valeur du CAC 40 et en même
temps de mettre un peu d'argent dans le
soutien d'une PME dans le du numérique
par par exemple et bien vous vous dites
mon panier CAC40 il est pas risqué mon
panier PME il est risqué c'est le
contraire le P le panier pas risqué
selon les canons de la gestion ben il
fait moin 80 % en 2 ans et puis l'autre
et ben il réussit donc c'est vraiment
cette appréciation du risque vraiment
quel chose cl aussi parce que les
banques centrales ont injecté énormément
de liquidité et que il y a certains
certains ont pris des positions en 2009
sur des bancaires en prévoyant le fait
que les États ne laisseraient pas tomber
les banqu ils ont fait énormément de
profit euh je vais pas vous citer le le
le gestionnaire d'un fond américain qui
a pris 7,9 milliards entre 2009 et
2011 c'est aussi une lecture si vous
avez une lecture un petit peu pervers du
système financier on peut faire
énormément d'argent je crois pas ce
qu'il y a de pervers à être baissier
lorsque le marché baisse non c'est pas
pas être baissier c'est pas être
baissier c'est de mettre des put option
à la baisse pour parier que ça va
baisser c'est une psychologie
d'investisseur qui qui qui peut être
respectable ou pas respectable ce n pas
ce n'est pas à N juger par contre parayz
que les États ne lâcheront pas leur
banque et faire de la spéculation
là-dessus ça peut être discutable on va
pas on va pas en revenir
dessus ça mériterait une autre interview
on va vous poser une dernière question
est-ce que mon collègue a d'autres
questions euh j'aurais bien aimé avoir
un petit mot de votre part sur le marché
transatlantique le marché
transatlantique et plus particulièrement
le fait que les très grosses sociétés on
pense évidemment à Monsanto puissent
demain éventuellement intenter un procès
à un pays ce qui est
[Musique]
totalement à l'heure actuelle mais cette
simple pensée me frise un peu les
neurones j'aurais souhaité savoir ce que
vous en
pensiez mett à la même échelle en fait
le marché transatlantique comprend des
société dont certaines ont des chiffres
d'affaires égal à un pourcentage
significatif de certains États européens
c'est une réalité bon elle crée de
l'emploi elle crée de la richesse
elles
sont sous la loupe des autorités
diverses américaines et européennes et
dans l'ensemble elle se comporte à peu
près bien dans l'ensemble alors est-ce
qu'il il y a des excès oui
hein récemment j'ai vu des des excès
dans dans dans la chimie et dans le
médical hein bon mais quand vous prenez
les 300 premières
sociétés
mondial je dirais que ma critique n'est
pas dans ce qu'ils font mais de ce
qu'ils ne font pas c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a plusieurs milliers de milliards de
dollars qui ne sont pas investi par ces
sociétés qui sont sur leur bilan et qui
alimentent certes la liquidité mondiale
mais nous aimerions mieux qu'ell les
investissent pour créer de la richesse
et de l'emploi et elles ne le font pas
et la vraie question c'est
pourquoi et la réponse et la réponse
c'est un manque de projet un manque de
visibilité non je pense pas je pense
que quand moi je connais des sociétés
qui ont 30 50 milliards de liquidité et
qui n'ont pas en interne à travers leur
centre de recherche à travers t tous les
éléments les propositions de de de leurs
commerçant créer suffisamment de
nouvelles idées qui elles doivent être
mises en œuvre et
donc on acccuse jamais mais il y a là un
problème de direction générale deux
dernières questions là on finit toujours
nos
interviews par des préconisations des
conseils Jean-Manuel rosant un conseil
pour les internautes qui nous regardent
euh choisissez le sujet alors si on si
on reste on je vais diviser en deux on
en a parlé à d' à d'autres occasions je
crois que les gens jeunes doivent
absolument comprendre internet c'est pas
du tout le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais il y
a des enjeux très très important
notamment au niveau de la vie privée sur
Internet aujourd'hui et il devrait dans
l'idéal en savoir le le maximum
notamment apprendre à coder ça leur
permettrait de comprendre exactement ce
qui se passe dans le monde d'innet mais
par ailleurs euh on est en France ici et
on est je crois très très très influencé
par l'esprit français par les problèmes
français par tout ce qui s'est passé ici
je crois que les gens évidemment en
France quand on parle de croissance
mondiale quand on dit à quel point ça va
viter bien et quand je vous dis
l'innovation dans le monde entier est en
train de changer le monde et on va vers
une croissance très très importante dans
les années qui viennent les gens nous
disent vous êtes fou vous parlez de quoi
donc je dis aux jeunes qui nous écoutent
c'est vrai c'est possible il faut le
ramener en France il faut aussi le faire
en France mais nous sommes dans une
période d'opportunité exceptionnelle
dans le
monde et il faut le plus possible voir
comment les autres pays
réussissentin pourquoi est-ce que les
États-Unis marchent si bien maintenant
et je
vais je vais vous donner un élément de
réponse
aux États-Unis l'année dernière il y a
eu
1003 d'émigrés qui sont venus dont
800000 si vous voulez sont venus des des
des des des des des des familles qui
sont qui où l'homme était parti et
ensuite la femme et les h enfants
regroupement familial et puis quelques
centaines de milliers sont venus pour
des raisons politiques mais il y a a eu
140000 hommes de ou femmes de compétence
venu du monde entier vous parlez vous
parlez des États-Unis vous parlez du
c'est pas la carte verte c'est la le
papier pour pouvoir drainer des des
cerveaux à l'extérieur absolument tout à
fait
et 140000
hein nous pendant cette
période on a perdu 30000 français
compétents c'est-à-dire par rapport à
notre population 65 contre
320 nous avons perdu autant en hommees
de compétence que les Américains ont
gagné en personne hommees et femme de
compétence et donc je dis que nous
devons veiller à ce point-là avec
acharnement à ne pas perdre nos
meilleurs éléments il y avait en
Belgique 3000 français dans la la
commune aisé il y en a 11000 il y a 5
ans il y en a 11000 aujourd'hui il y a
des dizaines de il y a
450000 français en Grande-Bretagne des
dizaines de milliers en Suisse et nous
avons perdu parmi les plus dynamiques
nous avons perdu entre 5 et 10 % des
Français les plus dynamiques pour
l'étranger et ça nous devons le
surveiller et
l'éviter moi j'allais dire simplement
pourquoi pourquoi ils partent pourquoi
ils partent j'imagine que c'est raison
financière non oui c'est pas simplement
c'est le fait que
depuis
1685 hein
euh les bon moi je viens d'une famille
qui a été protestante euh donc les les
élites qui font de l'argent qui créent
de la richesse sont mal vu ça a été le
cas en 1685 ça a été le cas à la fin euh
18 jamais de fum feu si si la la la la
population a cet esprit critique face à
l'homme riche c'est peut-être un manque
de transparence peut-être de l'envie
peut-être aussi de une réalité pour
certaines quand quand quand je ne crois
pas comment je ne crois pas mais je je
vais vous donner ma ma version des
chosand on vu certaines familles faire
de la spéculation pendant la guerre la
la deuxème guerre mondiale euh ça a
laissé quand même des traces au niveau
de certains donc respecter les gens qui
investissent et qui font de l'argent
c'est vrai en France on a on a un peu
tendance à à pas trop les respecter ce
qui est je pense une erreur parce que il
y a il faut avoir des leaders il faut
avoir des pointes de diamant des gens
qui prennent des risques mais il faut
aussi respecter les gens qui ont eu la
la ou qui ont vu certaines malversations
il faudrait il faudrait que la richesse
soit vertueuse et ce qu' l'aiderait le
plus à être vertueuse c'est qu'elle soit
transparente et assumée et on a en
France un très très grand problème
culturel qui est le suivant la France
c'est le pays de l'égalité égalité
liberté fraternité mais en France en
réalité on est libre de
tout sauf d'être différent on doit être
égal l'égalité est obligatoire dans les
pays anglo-saxons la différence est
assumée c'est-à-dire que le but de la
société c'est de permettre à chacun
d'assumer sa différence donc en France
quand on a une différence on est obligé
de la garder dans un périmètre caché et
quand sa différence à soit elle est pas
physique elle est pas par la mode elle
est pas par le foulard le turban ou
laakipa mais elle est par l'argent et
bien on la cache c'est le problème de la
France est entièrement que dans un monde
principalement libéral principalement
anglo-saxon principalement axé sur la
possibilité pour les individus d'avoir
accès à leur différence la France ne
peut pas mettre le droit à la différence
en avant on l'a vu une façon très simple
on a un président qui est élu en 2007 en
disant je vais faire une rupture on
comprend ce que c'est que cette rupture
cette rupture c'est je
vais vous obliger à exceller je vais
vous obliger à fonctionner ça va être
obligatoire alors on lui dit bon c'est
pas sympa mais on va te laisser essayer
ça marche pas et du coup on a un
président qui après est élu en dis
disant je vais être normal c'est-à-dire
je ne vais pas être différent les deux
sont excessifsv le mot de la
fin c'est la confiance dans l'avenir de
la France hein parce que nous avons 65
millions d'habitants que nous avons un
taux de croissance
important que nous avons heureusement un
taux d'émigration très important un tout
croiss démographique oui démographique
important que nous avons des gens qui
viennent d'un peu partout d'Europe et
d'Afrique du Nord qui veulent réussir et
que ces éléments là vont remuer
secouer la société française pour
qu'elle aille de l'avant et que j'ai
tout à fait confiance que dans les deux
trois décennies qui viennent ils
renouvelleront les élites de la France
dans un sens qui bénéficiera à
l'ensemble du pays messieurs
remercions merci à
vous ce qui est véritablement
intolérable c'est la surveillance de
masse comme le disait Eric Fillol c'est
la présomption de culpabilité
c'est des violations massives de nos
libertés individuelles qui ne peuvent en
aucun cas respecter le principe de
proportionnalité parce que on a enfin
rattrapé notre retard sur les américain
et puis on va pouvoir montrer à la NSA
que on s faireme aussi et on s faireme
on est bon on est super bon en matière
de surveillance après le le le souci
c'est pour la démocratie mais bon la
réalité du risque est camouflé à tous
les niveaux les banques ont des pertes
en interne très importantes qu'ell ne
montrent pas les banques centrales
n'exigent pas la transparence les an
chargé de faire les audites en dis
encore moins et les directions générales
se tèent dans toutes les langues
[Musique]